all right so given the fact that you're
very happily engaged now yes
do you look back on jigsaw
in a different light and in your thought
process around jigsaw differently or
no
and it's
the thing that annoys me is the amount
of people who the man i get it like i
know it's a joke most of the time when
people call me a hypocrite like it's
it's the joke i'd [ __ ] make like i
get it
but
at a purely a personal whiny level i'm
like i'm not a hypocrite jigsaw was
never i never once said love wasn't real
the whole point was it definitely exists
and that's what i was after it was meant
to be the whole point was you know i
kept forcing myself into relationships
because i was so desperate to be in a
relationship because that's what i
thought i had to do
i would compromise myself so much in
relationships because that's what i've
learned relationships were about what
about sacrifice and about sacrificing
part of yourselves for the greater good
of this relationship so you and this
person can be together forever and then
just you know settling and giving up and
you know compromising your own happiness
for the sake
of
the
the great good night and i didn't i was
like that's [ __ ] like i don't i
refuse to believe that's what a
relationship is that's what i've done so
many times and i've hated all those
relationships so now i'm going to i'm
going to make sure that in the future
you have to love 100 of who i am and
that was all thank you like you have to
truly love me for all of me and i have
found someone like that don't get me
wrong it's weird like you think you want
it and then you find somebody who
actually loves 100 of you and you're
like oh you're [ __ ] up
like that like you shouldn't you
definitely shouldn't love all of me like
there are now that you love all of me i
guess i do kind of have to admit that i
am a flawed person and maybe you
shouldn't love those flaws because if
you love them i'll not improve them and
it would be nice to you know i only hold
my hold myself to a certain level uh but
because i love you more than i love
myself it would be nicer for you to but
you know carry me up and
um but even then i i think she she just
wants the best for me and she as long as
i'm happy
she's happy and that is exactly the type
of relationship i was yelling about
and and the one that you should settle
for like the whole thing was she is bet
for me she's better than being single
and that was always i was like yeah
being single was so much fun for me that
if you were going to get me into a
relationship it had to be [ __ ] better
it had to be no and the second it
stopped being better than being single
i'm out that [ __ ] relationship
because the other thing is good i'm
always going to go for what makes me
happier now definitely happier than i
was when i was single consistently all
the time um not been any the only
arguments we've ever had so far is when
i'm being the psychopath
and that was just like during the
pandemic and that was a narcissist going
from all the attention in the world to
none of it so it was just some
adjustments on my side some people use
that lack of love from the other side
it's like a
that's an attractive quality or like
elements that the other side pulls away
you know when people get too keen or
when people do begin to love 100 of you
you can actually start to pull away from
that because you think hang on if i
don't fully love myself and this person
does [ __ ] there must be something wrong
with them which means they shouldn't be
in a relationship with them it's so
bizarre that the thing that we've wanted
all along which is for someone to accept
us for our flaws you know warts and all
successes and all to support us through
good times and bad when someone does do
that because we have such an inherently
poor own self-image we actually to get
turned off by that yeah yeah and i but i
think you can get beyond that you just
have to acknowledge that's what is
happening
there what is that is somebody's truly
loving
you for who you are
it's
it's not a lack of it it's not a bad
thing on their part you should use that
to go right they do love who all of i am
and i love them so much i should be
better because i want to [ __ ] bar it
i don't want to make them love a piece
of [ __ ] like i don't mind my own like we
could all hate our own reputation but if
i'm just walking around looking like
[ __ ] smelling like [ __ ] and they still
love me that's very irresponsible of me
like i should be making them you know
they're always going to be probably yeah
but i should be doing my best to make
sure that other people aren't going have
you seen what she's let him get away
with
like he's shy he's a beast now he's a
smelly decrepit beast i can't and no she
still loves him she says his heart's
good apparently yeah [ __ ] weird
another thing is when people if you fall
quite hard for someone if you love
someone very quickly or if you're
spending a little bit of time the same
thing can happen if you get too keen too
fast
the amount of game playing i think this
is something that i struggled with a lot
during my 20s because i wanted to be
loved like i really really wanted i'm
quite an affectionate person which i
think that you are as well like i just
really really wanted to be loved and
have an emotional connection with
somebody and what it leads to is you
your emotions end up being further ahead
of how you're displaying your emotions
to the other person so like your
emotions are moving at a thousand miles
an hour and you're like right yeah but i
need to pump the brakes on what i'm
actually texting this person or saying
to them in front so you end up playing
this like weird reserved game version of
you because you know if you come on too
strong too fast this person's going to
go away yeah trying to decode each
other's messages like where like i
i don't know like there were so many
things i did love about being single but
man it was stressful that boys are like
is this the right thing to how long
should i wait to reply should i wait
like is the is is this is this too
forward like i don't want to make this
person comfortable but is it not or is
it not forward
enough like have i made and also have i
made sure that like you know uh if it is
just a fling i'm after it they know that
that's what the goal is and i'm not like
yeah i'm not tricking someone to i'm not
making someone feel like i'm after a
relationship like i'm not giving them
mixed signals but let's also make sure
that i'm not getting [ __ ] mixed
signals like like let's make sure i'm
making it edits yeah a whole bunch it's
a [ __ ] minefield man like this is the
thing this is the thing for the boomers
out there office someone that's been in
a relationship for ages that's looking
at tinder and [ __ ] only five you
would be [ __ ] at it every single one of
you wouldn't last a [ __ ] second it
would be like signing up to the army now
you decrepit old [ __ ] you'd be shot
dead by a sniper you didn't even know
was on the field
like it would just it would be a [ __ ]
drone strike and you're over like i yeah
none of you none of you if you're over
40 it's over what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you